انا بحس حالي انه موجود فيهم لانه انا ما
كنت عم يشطفوله صرت طفولته الاولاد وعم
نغير الصوره النمطيه اللي انبنت بدعشر سنه
عن اللاجئ السوري
[تصفيق]
واحد واحد
[موسيقى]
انا اخذ سوريا
بلبنان تقريبا بحدود 11 سنه جينا بدايه
الازمه
فعشت تقريبا بحدود الست سنين مخيم بعدين
تالت على بيت
وبلشت فكره هيك بعد ما طلعت عالبيت انه
يكون أمسح صور الاولاد بالمخيمات توصل
صوره شوي ايجابيه وغير النمطيه اللي هي
اعطونا على الناس عم تنقلها بطريقه سلبيه
انه هون اهل المخيمات كتير بحاجه مثلا
مساعدات غذائيه وهن كتير جوعانين وهن
عطشانين انا رحت على موضوع ثاني
الاولاد
بمحل ما انه خلاص بس دعم نفسي برعايه من
محل تاني انه ندعمهم المعنويه ندعمهم
بالتعليم بشيء ثاني فكنت دائما بوصل على
محل الايجابي ما بحاول وصل الفكره السلبيه
دائره
[موسيقى]
منورها للصور يلي كنت مصورهم بطريقه
ايجابيه وصلت لمرحله كانوا يجيبوا الف
مشاهده الفين لمرحله صاروا يجيبوا 800 الف
كتير ناس بلدان يعني غريبه انا اول مره
اسمع اسمها صاروا يعرفوا
لازم بكفي لازم بكفي وكثير شان شي حافز
حتى للاطفال انه صارت في ناس من برا تيجي
خلص بدنا نروح على القدر الاولاد الاولاد
يعني ما كانوا بده مساعده كانوا بس بدهم
يلعبوا معهم كتير من اوقات
انا ماني قادر
كتير ناس عم تتفاعل بتقول نحن راح نقدم
هالشي
[موسيقى]
بعد ازمه اللي صارت
لبنان
قادرين يدفعوا
بالمدارس وكورونا فمثلا صار لنا اربع سنين
الولد اللي كان لازم يدخل صف اول صار اربع
سنين ما دخل لازم يكون ولا هو صف رابع ما
بيعرف يقرا ولا يكتب يعني صار عمره 12 سنه
فصرت اجي انا بتعرف تقرا قال لي لا تعرف
قديه عمرك
كتير صدمه انه بتسال الولد قديش عمرك ما
بعرف انا قدي عمري اصلا
فقررنا نعمل شيء انا شخص سوي رفيقي من
الكويت نعمل مبادره صغيره نعمل خيمه بمخيم
علم الولاد القراءه والكتابه بعدين الفكره
صار معنا شوي ليش احنا بنطورها بنعمل خيمه
ثانيه بمخيم ثاني
رجعنا على مخيم ثالث مخيم رابع مخيم خامس
بعدين رجعنا انه هاي القيمه ما بتتناسب مع
الاولاد كتير خلينا نكون عم نعملها خيمه
اكثر
تجذبهم انه كانه مدرسه فيها رسومات فيها
صوبيا لحتى يتدفوا بالشتويه مروحه حتى
تدفوا بالصيف مدرسه انجليزي مدرسه لغه
عربيه محفظ القران الكريم فصلنا كل مره
نطور وصلنا لخيمه كتير يعني صراحه من صفر
لتسعين بالمئه لازم كلنا نعرف كل واحد شو
حلمه
بمحل ما كل المؤسسات اللي بتشتغل اللي
بتيجي بتعطي كل الكرتون الاغاثيه او
مساعده للعيله وناس في ولد بحاجه لعبه
بحاجه ولد يتاخد على محل مثلا مدينه ملاهي
يلعب يشوف بتلوبه لغيره
يعني تقريبا كنت من وقت محدود الخمس ساعات
ست ساعات كتير هذا الوقت كنت
بحاجتهم هلا بس صار عم يتعلموا ما صرت اجي
لعندهم بنفس الوقت انه اذا اجيت هلا
بس يطلعوا يلعبوا يتركوا المدرسه ويطلعوا
يلعبوا لا خلاص اتركوا تعلموا وعم تابعوهم
من بعيد لبعيد
بفلان قديه تطور الطالب الفلاني بدي اطور
فرحان
محمد مين تعلم منه انجلش اليوم نتعلم
القران نخلص الايه الفلانيه مين خلص
الكلمه الفلانيه فكثير من بعيد لبعيد
انا هلا تقريبا بحدود ال 150 طفل بخمس
مخيمات بخمس قيم يعني اعمار تتراوح من خمس
سنين 13 سنه بحلم انه بعد فتره بيكونوا عم
يروح على مدرسه كتير نموذجيه كل حدا منهم
صار قادر يتعلم يعمل حلمه في منه كتير
حابين
بحلم انه يوصلوا ان شاء الله وبيطلعوا
بالنهايه اخر شيء بدنا نطلعوا من المخيمات
اتركو
ها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]